I I think sometimes the Janelle has pit
me against the boys or never supported
me with the boys I man I'm having the
hardest time not just feeling like she's
just betraying me I'm not saying that
they have to actually apologize to me
and I corrected that many times already
and she keeps hitting that note
it's almost like that's what she's told
them so she can't back off on it because
they're trying to put the heat on to me
for what's been going on here but you
told them all until they apologized they
can't well that's what you told me
that's what you told me you said until
the show with respect and apologize
then
so
and then after the after Christmas
Christine said that Isabelle and
everybody are coming home and they want
to come see the family here I meant this
is exactly what I was afraid of with
Christine leaving
but it it just was working out that we
had a vacation rental so we extended it
so Christine and her kids could come so
they can see the truly and Isabel can
see you
okay am I the only one that sees this as
some kind of betrayal
a betrayal
Christine just left
you don't want her to bring the kids to
see you
oh I'd like to see the kids but you're
talking about everybody going to some
neutral zone this is my house the last I
knew is that they boys couldn't come
until they shoot or showed respect and
apologized so they're like well I guess
we'll come and
stay with you and I don't have room for
him
you guys are going to have to weigh in
on this I'm not going to shoulder this
whole damn thing
so now he's looking for re inforcement
from Robin and Mary let's build a united
front against Janelle in her decisions
I'm struggling here with the Christmas
scenario so I'm asking Mary and Robin to
chime in like I can't identify what it
is specifically about it bothering me I
was like is this bothering you guys
what do you want us to comment on
I mean have an opinion here this is
bugging the hell out of me am I wrong
[Music]